I have these uh these bad allergies I
went to the drugstore to get Claire
dandy and they make you sign a form to
promise you're not gonna make meth I
feel like if you're in a selling meth
the waiver is not really a deterrent is
there some drug kingpin going down the
like not only did he sell
methamphetamine
he lied to Monique at Wolverine he's a
monster that's a perk I didn't know
about meth if you do it you probably
don't get allergies cool you're walking
around bitching about the pollen count
some dude calls out of a dumpster he's
like I didn't even notice too busy
trying to find my kids
I saw a dad in the coffee shop quizzing
the Sun on dinosaurs every 30 seconds he
would hold up a picture of a dinosaur
and his son would be like that's a
Stegosaurus and a dad would say good job
Steven well done why are we quizzing
kids on dinosaurs I've never needed that
knowledge ever in my life it's never
come in handy it's never gotten me out
of a jam I've know been driving drunk
some cop pulls me over he's like what
kind of dinosaurs are going I'm like a
Stegosaurus he's like step out of the
vehicle we should be quizzing kids on
things they're gonna need in life this
should be the quiz he holds up a photo
of the same woman but slightly different
pictures he's like oh right Steven
what's different and the kids like her
haircut he's like very good that's gonna
get you out of so much trouble
then another photo of a woman he's like
is she angry
it's like she's gonna say she's not but
I think she really is the dad's like
dude you're good at this Wow
you're better than me that's why I only
get to see you on weekends I had I had a
breakup with a girl and she was mad I
didn't cry she's like you're not crying
during this breakup are you crying doing
that magic Johnson documentary maybe
that should show you how to add a touch
with reality she is that she thinks
she's in the same inspiration category
as the greatest point guard that ever
lived
that guy played in the all-star game
with HIV she would have sex with me when
she had a headache you know that one's
mostly for the fellas but you know
I love Magic Johnson you know every
endorsement converse 7up he never got
frozen but he deserved to get it
if you were on the fence about wearing
protection and he saw Magic Johnson's
face and the box should be like we
should definitely wear a condom there's
no question this is the commercial
you're coming out of a blackout you wake
up next to a very regrettable one-night
stand you see a little picture of
Magic's face in the box you like I'll
magic thanks for the assist
break up to their painful breakups you
know when people propose they make it
nice they hide the ring in food you know
they do something fun
people should break up creatively that
would soften it that's what I want to do
hand a girl a broken iPhone she's like
Sam this isn't working I say exactly
it's fun I feel like even if she cried
five minutes later she'd beg it was
clever I like my phone better than
people and it's not close I dropped him
the toilet we slide to rush it to the
Apple store like it was the ER they were
like there's nothing we can do and I was
devastated I would almost rather lose a
loved one that my father almost not my
mom or dad but our non-core it's not
even a question I love my grandpa didn't
check them every 30 seconds
look he was 89 the phone was brand-new
so yeah I think it'd be cool for when
your grandpa died if they gave you an
upgrade that'd be kind of cool buddy a
better old dude you wouldn't take it I
just hand him you're like he's just like
your grandpa but he doesn't say the
n-word I'd be like that is an upgrade
huh does he still say oriental though
yeah we can fix everything so grandpa
five not the grandpa five s so much I
love my phone you ever have someone
telling you a boring story and you can
feel your hand shaking and reaching
toward your phone my phone whenever born
me like this [ __ ]
cuz I'm trained in YouTube videos I know
how much time is left you know I wish
they do that with people they're telling
you a terrible story you tap their face
you like thank God thank you very much
guys
[Applause]